Das ist jetzt auch neu, die hatte ich noch nie.
Diese Meldung hatte ich noch nie.
Lull.
Na gut, wird eben auch sein.
Dann, äh, connecten wir nochmal.
Oh Leute, ich muss unbedingt eine USB-Festplatte dran machen.
Das war mal nach der Runde.
Ich muss unbedingt eine USB-Festplatte dran machen.
Das ist jetzt auch neu.
Für Gameplay.
Ich hab kaum Platz.
Hallo, Game, please.
Scheinst du heute nochmal?
Ah, ich bin online.
Alles klar, Game.
Natürlich, ich bin online.
Wusste ich gar nicht.
Äußerst interessant zu wissen, dass ich online bin.
Okay, dann können wir immer die Recording-Einstellungen ändern.
Äh, temporary files.
Genau.
Äh, nein, nein, nein, nicht da rein.
Da rein.
Kannst du den Rec-Ordner wieder leaken?
Zack.
Klar.
Hard-Overlay-FPS-Counter.
Hat sich Battlefield jetzt...
Nein, Battlefield hat sich immer noch nicht gefangen.
Weil ich online bin.
Alles klar.
Jetzt vielleicht?
Aha, okay. Wunderbar.
Hat ein bisschen gedauert, bis Battlefield das Ganze gecheckt hat.
Aber ich hoffe, jetzt funktioniert's.
Login.
Post-Champ.
Spielst du aktuell in den Gamen?
Viel Battlefield 3 spiel ich ja gar nicht.
Ja, ich spiel ab und zu ein bisschen Passive Exide, aber das war's eigentlich.
Wobei ich die Season auch nicht gespielt hab.
Gibt ja nix.
Okay, was sind wir? Defender? Attacker?
Stelzer?
Äh, wir sind Defender. Okay.
Excellent.
Oh, da ist direkt ein Panzer. Ah nee, das sind Freunde der Panzer.
Panz-Man.
Okay, wo stellst du die rum?
Hier links. Da, da.
Oh, Big Brain.
Wo ist er?
Lul, lul.
Boah, die Sau.
Das hätt ich jetzt nicht gedacht, dass der mich hier weg basht.
Äh.
Da hab ich mir den Jet gerechnet. Ich dachte hier easy einfach mal warten und zack.
Und dann, aber nee.
Pech gehabt.
Du hast mich doppelt.
Oh guck mal, der Peng ist am Start.
Lul.
Äh, tja.
Du guckst um mein Weihnachtsvideo?
Das wäre natürlich exquisite.
Ah.
Oh, dieses Spotting durch die Wand.
Das ist so OPS.
So OPS.
Fuck.
Lul.
Okay, okay. Pass mal auf, ich zeig euch
den Postchamp-Spot schlechthin.
Hier, Postchamp, Postchamp-Spot.
Ah nee, gar keiner da.
Okay. Oder?
Weil das ist eigentlich nice, da kann man durchgucken, wenn da Gegner sind.
Aber da sind keine Gegner. So, wir rushen jetzt vor.
Ich mein, das heißt nicht umsonst rush.
Wird gerusht. Bashen, Alter.
Bashen. Bashen. Huge Bash.
Die kleinen Noobs, die kleinen...
Oh.
Oh, what the?
Der Panzer? Ich glaub's
nicht. Der Delay
ist 30 Sekunden.
30 Sekunden Delay.
Weihnachtsnoobs, nee, es sind...
Ehrlich gesagt sind es...
Oh, was ist hier?
Warum darf der... Warum ist es ihm
gestattet, die Legehämme zu vollführen?
Das ist nicht erlaubt.
Captain Peng hat aufgehört, aber er ist angeblich
immer noch in meinem Team. Oh nee, jetzt ist er weg.
But why?
Warum ist er weg?
Oh, oh, da kommt ein AAV.
Lass mich weg hier.
Die steigen jetzt aus.
Oder kann ich gebashen, wenn sie hier aussteigen?
Okay, ich weiß nicht, wo sie hin sind.
Irgendwo.
Oder...
Ich seh Gegner.
Jetzt können wir...
Um die Ecke gucken, Champ machen.
He.
Damit hält er nicht.
Pass mal auf. Oh nee.
Ich wollte wieder Belebungs-Champ
machen, hat aber nicht funktioniert.
Enemy-Sniper.
Ich hab ja immer noch
Albträume von der
Bad Company 2-Sniper,
von diesem Sniper-Announcement,
wo der Typ herumgeschrien hat.
It's a Sniper.
Und in Bad Company 2
haben die Typen rumgesessen.
Ey, ich glaub's nicht.
Oh, oh, oh, Panzer.
Alter, geh weg.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, Panzer.
Panzer, ja, ist gut, komm.
Alter, der ist immer noch da.
Hier kommt noch einer lang, glaube.
Okay, hier wird's mir ein bisschen
zu post-champig gerade.
Achtung, wir machen
Stels-Taktik.
Massive-Stels-Taktik.
Okay, äh,
keiner mehr da.
Alles gut, hat ja wunderbar funktioniert.
Fatal, falls du mitmachen willst.
Du hast mich an der Liste, kannst ja
von dem Server nachjoinen.
Wäre auf jeden Fall äußerst
pock. Falls das die Runde nicht klappt,
join ich dann rüber, nächste Runde.
Passt mal auf hier, jetzt, jetzt wollen wir den
Post-Champ, Extrem-Post-Champ machen wir jetzt.
Oh ne, das ist ja ein Panzer.
Massive-Extreme-Post-Champ.
Übrigens, ich sollte hier nicht so viel spammen,
ne, das ist eigentlich total, total
dumm.
Eigentlich total dumm hier zu
spammen, weil, dann trifft man
nix, wenn man spammt.
Spam-Champ.
Achtung.
Nein!
Aber ich hab ihn noch, bam, hier, Teamplay, Leute.
Kann mir keiner vorwerfen, ich würde hier, wäre hier
nicht der Teamplayer.
Jaja, klar Fatal, ist noch Platz frei.
Ich komm mal sogar hier, sogar,
sogar hier im Team, ist, ist noch.
Hm.
Ey komm, ich bleib mal hier.
Aha!
So, wo, wo
stellst du die denn rum, hier in der Mitte?
Übrigens, Terran Highway ist total
Defender. Wie, wie
sagt man das in CS?
Defender
sited.
Aber richtig
Defender sited, also, das ist total
unfair eigentlich.
Achtung, Achtung hier.
Peek-Champ.
What?
Was zum?
Ernsthaft, das hat er nicht
gekillt? Wollt ihr mich veräppeln?
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Drei Kilometer, ey,
ich hab, ich hab den 30 Schuss
reingeballert. Hat er nicht
gejuckt?
Don't care-Champ.
No grenade!
Oh fuck.
Ja, das hier ist aber
richtig Defender sited.
Einmal CT und
TT-lastig kann man hier schlecht
sagen, weil es sind ja, oh nice,
danke. Es sind ja keine
T's und CTs hier.
Es sind ja Coconers
Konas und Kekommerz, okay ich habe die Idee leute es ist es nennt sich jetzt offiziell Kekommerz sided
Kekommerz sided oder oder Kekommerz sided
Sterben please
Ich würde sagen das hier ist ganz schön Kekommerz sided, okay ich warte jetzt bis die hier raus, raus kommen
Ey ich fasse es nicht, okay okay ich mach Rats, Rats Champ
Die sind bestimmt schon down, ey leute jetzt wir machen den flank wir machen den flank pass auf
Yolo flank easy easy yolo flank
Achtung Achtung Achtung
Mist ich wollte jetzt den huge play machen
Fatal bist du eigentlich drin?
Bist du Gegner?
Sehen jetzt nicht
Jetzt wusste man sich schon wieder mit den Leuten kloppen wer wen wiederbeleben darf
Oh da hinten ist der Schneiberman, seht ihr ihn hier? Da ist der Schneiberman
Das Schneiberman
So jetzt jetzt aber huge huge flank leute massive flank
Massive flank
So was ist das scheiß
Wuhuhuh meine money ist leer
Bad Comedy 2 hat noch ein paar server, ja das ist richtig
Ah da ist er
X fatal, ich mach mal ein neues squad auf
Ich mach mal ein neues squad auf
Ah da ist er, perfekt
Äh und ich switche mal um auf äh sprint money money
Nice, auf gehts
So muss das sein
Also Bad Company 2 ich hab's letztens mal wieder gespielt, letztens ein halbes Jahr her oder so
Hat sich immer noch ganz gut, haben wir das nicht sogar mal im stream kurz angeguckt
Spielt sich immer noch ganz gut
Aber Bad Company 2 finde ich braucht deutlich länger bis man wieder reingekommen ist wie in Bad Company
Äh wie in Battlefield 3
Aber man, der Schneiberdude ey der nervt mich das die ganze Zeit da drüben am rumschneibern
Ich mein springen tut ihnen das ja, Achtung ich probiers jetzt mal
Ich probiers jetzt mal, YOLO, YOLO mode äh
So
Easy
Valparaiso only server
Och nee, Valparaiso, ich glaub ich hab sogar Pornvaldas gespielt
Da irgendwas, ach da unten ist er
Okay hier geht, hier geht jetzt ja ehrlich gesagt grad nicht allzu viel
Die kommen ja gar nicht aus dem spawn raus
Guck mal der Tesswood, ist der Tesswood hier im Panzer drin, ach da ist er
Okay, wollt grad sagen wie hast denn ihr sonst 22 null
Als Infanterie rumrennen Mensch bestimmt
Soldier
Soldier 76 bestimmt nicht
Das war ja in Battlefield 4 cool ne
In Battlefield 4 hat es ja diese aufsammelbaren Kids
Teamplayer, Teamplayer
Teamplayer Deluxe
Habt ihr das gesehen
Die kommen überhaupt nicht vor äh, was willst du denn hier machen
Harvest Day, aber Harvest Day war auch nass
Ich muss ehrlich sagen ich fand mehr oder weniger alle Bad Company 2 Maps
Ganz brauchbar
Okay also hier geht nichts, ich kann noch nicht mal Punkte machen
Ich kann einfach dastehen, muss nix machen
Hier wieder, Massive Teamplayer
Massive Teamplayer
Äh, lass mal überlegen
Also meine Lieblingsmap in Bad Company 2 war eindeutig
Val, nee Pornvaldas, Pornvaldas das war auch die Beta Map
Und ich muss sagen im nachhinein betrachtet
Ich finde Pornvaldas immer noch die beste, einer der besten Rushmaps
Ist einfach zu geil
Äh Leute ist mein Stream kaputt
Ich hab nur 720p, 48 kann das sein
Warum, warum hab ich keine 1080p
Warum hab ich keine 1080p
Seht ihr das
Ist es bei euch 1080p oder 720p
Ist es bei euch